so what's your intuition here you got
you had a conversation with Sam Harris
recently that was uh sort of um
you've had a bit of a disagreement and
you're sticking on this point you know
Elon Musk uh Stuart Russell
kind of have us worry existential
threats of AI what's your intuition why
if we engineer increasingly intelligent
neurocortex type of system in the
computer why that shouldn't be a thing
that we it was interesting use the word
intuition and Sam Harris used the word
intuition too and and we didn't use that
intuition that word I immediately
stopped and said oh that's the question
of the problem he's using intuition I'm
not speaking about my intuition yes I'm
speaking about something I understand
something I'm going to build something I
am building something I understand
completely or at least well enough to
know what it's all I'm guessing I know
what this thing's going to do
and I think most people who are worried
they have trouble separating out I mean
they don't have they don't have the
knowledge or the understanding about
like what is intelligence how is it
manifest in the brain how is it separate
from these other functions in the brain
and so they imagine it's going to be
human-like or animal-like it's going to
have it's going to have the same sort of
drives and emotions we have but there's
no reason for that that's just because
there's there's unknown if you're if the
unknown is like oh my God you know I
don't know what this is going to do we
have to be careful it could be like us
but really smarter I'm saying no it
won't be like us it'll be really smart
but it won't be like us at all and um
and but I I'm coming from that not
because I just guessing I'm not
intuitive using intuition I'm basically
like okay I understand this thing works
this is what it does it makes money to
you okay but uh to push back so I also
disagree with the the intuitions that
Sam has but
but I also disagree with what you just
said which you know what's a good uh
analogy so if you look at the Twitter
algorithm in in the early days just
recommender systems you can understand
how recommender systems work
what you can't understand in the early
days is when you apply that recommender
system at scale to thousands and
millions of people how that can change
societies yeah so the question is yes
you're just saying this is how an
engineer in your cortex works but the
ques like when you have a very useful uh
Tick Tock type of service that goes
viral when your neurocortex goes viral
yeah and then millions of people start
using it can that destroy the world no
uh well first of all this is back one
thing I want to say is that uh AI is a
dangerous technology I don't I'm not
denying that all technology is dangerous
well an AI maybe particularly so yeah
okay so um am I worried about it yeah
I'm totally worried about it the the
thing where the the narrow component
we're talking about now is the
existential risk of AI right so I want
to make that distinction because I think
AI can be applied poorly it can be
applied in ways that you know people are
going to understand the consequences of
it
um these are all potentially Very Bad
Things
but they're not the AI system creating
this existential risk on its own and
that's the only place I disagree with
other people right so so I I think the
existential risk thing is uh humans are
really damn good at surviving so to kill
off the human race and be very very you
could even yes but you can even I'll go
further I don't think AI systems are
ever going to try to I don't think AR
systems are ever going to like say I'm
going to ignore you I'm going to do what
I think is best
um I don't think that's gonna happen at
least not in the way I'm talking about
it so you the Twitter recommendation
algorithm is interesting example
let's let's use computers and analogy
again right
I build a computer it's a universal
Computing machine I can't predict what
people are going to use it for they can
build all kinds of things they can they
can even create computer viruses it's
you know all kinds of stuff
so there's some unknown about its
utility and about where it's going to go
but on the other hand I pointed out that
once I build a computer it's not going
to fundamentally change how it computes
it's like I use the example of a
register which is a part internal part
of a computer
um you know I say it can't just sit
there because computers don't evolve
they don't replicate they don't evolve
they don't you know the physical
manifestation of the computer itself is
not going to there's certain things it
can't do right so we can break into
things like things that are possible to
happen we can't predict and things are
just impossible to happen unless we go
out of our way to make them happen
they're not going to happen unless
somebody makes them happen yeah so
there's there's a bunch of things to say
one is the physical aspect which you're
absolutely right we have to build a
thing for it to operate in the physical
world and you can just stop building
them
uh you know the moment they're not doing
the thing you want them to do or just
change the design or change the design
the question is I mean there's uh it's
possible in the physical world this is
probably longer term is you automate the
building it makes it makes a lot of
sense to automate the building there's a
lot of factories that are doing more and
more and more automation to go from raw
resources to the final product it's
possible to imagine that obviously much
more efficient to keep to create a
factory that's creating robots that do
something uh you know do something
extremely useful for society it could be
uh personal assistance it could be uh it
could be it could be your toaster but a
toaster that's much has a deeper
knowledge of your culinary preferences
yeah
and and that could uh well I think now
you've hit on the right thing the real
thing we need to be worried about Lex is
self-replication
right that is the thing that we're in
the physical world yeah or even the
virtual world self-replication because
self-replication is dangerous it's
probably more likely to be killed by a
virus you know or a human engineered
virus anybody can create a you know this
the technology is getting so almost
anybody well not anybody but a lot of
people could create a human engineered
virus that could wipe out Humanity
that is really dangerous no intelligence
required just self-replication
so
um so we need to be careful about that
so when I think about you know AI I'm
not thinking about robots building
robots don't do that don't build a you
know just well that's because you're
interested in creating intelligence it
seems like self-replication
is a good way to make a lot of money
well fine but so is you know maybe
editing viruses is a good way too I
don't know the point is if as a society
when we want to look at existential
risks
the existential risks we face that that
we can control almost all evolve around
self-replication yes my question is I
don't see a good uh way to make a lot of
money by engineering viruses and
deploying them on the world there could
be there could be applications that are
useful but let's separate out let's
separate out I mean you don't need to
you only need some you know terrorists
who wants to do it because it doesn't
take a lot of money to make viruses
um let's just separate out what's risky
and what's not risky I'm arguing that
the intelligence side of this equation
is not risk it's not risk it's not risk
at all it's the self-replication side of
the equation it's risky and I'm not
dismissing that I'm scared as hell it's
like the paper clip maximizer thing yeah
those are often like talked about in the
same conversation
um I think you're right like creating
Ultra intelligence super intelligent
systems
is not necessarily coupled with a
self-replicating arbitrarily
self-replicating systems yeah and you
don't get Evolution unless you're
self-replicating yeah and so I think
that's just this argument that people
have trouble separating those two out
they just think oh yeah intelligence
looks like us and look how look at the
damage we've done to this planet like
how we've you know destroyed all these
other species yeah well we replicate we
have eight billion of us or seven
billion of us now so
um I think the idea is that the the more
intelligent we're able to build systems
the more tempting
it becomes from a capitalist perspective
of creating products the more tempting
it becomes to create self uh
reproduction systems all right so let's
say that's true so does that mean we
don't build intelligence systems no that
means we regulate we we understand the
risks uh we regulate them yeah uh you
know look there's a lot of things we
could do with society which have some
sort of financial benefit to someone
which could do a lot of harm
and we have to learn how to regulate
those things we have to learn how to
deal with those things I will argue this
I would say the opposite like I would
say having intelligent machines at our
disposal will actually help us in the
end more because it'll help us
understand these risks better and help
us mitigate these risks better there
might be ways of saying oh well how do
we solve climate change problems you
know how do we do this or how do we do
that
um that just like computers are
dangerous in the hands of the wrong
people but they've been so great for so
many other things we live with those
dangers and I think we have to do the
same with intelligent machines we just
but we have to be constantly Vigilant
about this idea of a Bad actors doing
bad things with them and B
um don't ever ever create a
self-replicating system
um uh and and by the way I don't even
know if you could create a
self-replicating system that uses a
factory that's really dangerous you know
Nature's Way of self-uppocating is so
amazing
um you know it doesn't require anything
it just you know the thing and resources
and it goes right yeah
um if I said to you you know what we
have to build uh our goal is to build a
factory that can make that builds new
factories and it has to end-to-end
supply chain that's the it has to bind
the resources get the energy
I mean that's really hard it's you know
no one's doing that in the next you know
100 years I've been extremely impressed
by the efforts of Elon Musk and Tesla to
try to do exactly that not
not from raw resource well he actually I
think States the goal is to go from raw
resource to the uh the final car in one
Factory yeah that's that's the main goal
of course it's not currently possible
but they're taking huge leaps well he's
not the only one to do that this has
been a goal for many uh Industries for a
long long time
um it's difficult to do well a lot of
people what they do is instead they have
like a million suppliers and then they
like there's everybody's Madness
co-locate them and they and they tie the
systems together it's a fundamental
distribution I think that's that also is
not getting at the issue I was just
talking about um which is
self-replication it's
um I mean self-replication means there's
no
entity involved other than the entity
that's replicating
um right and so if there's humans in
this in the loop that's not really
self-replicating right it's Unless
somehow we're duped
but it's also I I don't necessarily
agree with you because you've kind of
mentioned that AI will not say no to us
I just think they will yeah yeah so like
uh
I think it's a useful feature to build
in I'm just trying to like uh put myself
in the mind of Engineers to sometimes
say no
you know if you you yeah
I gave the example earlier right I gave
the example my car yeah right my car
turns the wheel and and applies the
accelerator and the brake as I say until
it decides there's something dangerous
yes and then it doesn't do that yeah now
that was something it didn't decide to
do it's something we programmed into the
car uh and so good it was a good idea
right the question again isn't like if
we create an intelligent system will it
ever
ignore our commands of course we will
and sometimes is it going to do it
because it came up came up with its own
goals that serve its purposes and it
doesn't care about our purposes no I
don't think that's going to happen